Listen up, bro: Fans have found a
strange criticism of the dialogue
in The Way of Water — and you'll
never guess what it could be…
Unless you've been living under a giant rock on a
planet far, far, away, you are probably aware that
James Cameron's blockbuster Avatar: The Way of
Water has hit theaters across the United States.
"Back together, 13 years later, pretty exciting."
"Yeah, it is, right?"
The online discussion around the movie has been
mostly favorable, with plenty of praise mixed in
with a few critiques — namely, the relatively
thin plot and more than three-hour run time.
The second installment in James Cameron's
planned five-film arc also earned kudos
for the stunning visual effects and its
criticism of Earth's wasteful capitalist ways.
"What does Eywa's heartbeat sound like?"
"Mighty."
However, some fans are pointing out
that a particular scripting choice is
at best unintentionally hilarious,
and at worst kinda distracting.
Much of Avatar: The Way of Water centers
on the children of Jake Sully and Neytiri,
as well as the teenagers of
the seafaring Metkayina clan.
While the dialogue seems to be one of the most
criticized aspects of the film in general,
the frequent usage of the word "bro"
by the male teenage characters had
many viewers cringing in their seats. In
the official discussion thread for the
film on the r/movies subreddit, one user wrote:
"Bro... I lost count of how many
times they called each other bro..."
Another user observed:
"That's how teenagers talk. Loved it."
One Redditor was less gracious,
commenting that the overuse of
"bro" was their biggest gripe
about the movie. They said:
"Why do they talk like that? They wouldn't have
gotten that from Jake, he is too old to talk like
that. Seems like an old man writing characters
to relate to a modern teenage audience."
"How do you do, fellow kids?"
James Cameron is 68 and co-screenwriter Rick
Jaffa is 66, of course, so this user seems
spot on with their analysis. Another user was
more accommodating to the choice and wrote:
"That's actually how people talk.
I'm 28 and I still start a ton of
sentences with 'bro...' when
I'm hanging with my friends."
While not every commenter volunteered
their ages, those up on more modern
slang asserted that teens really don't
say "bro" anymore. One Redditor said:
"'Bruh' is the actual saying these days."
The point raised about how the teenagers
would have even learned such language is
valid. These characters do not have
American pop culture to learn from,
and it's a bit of a stretch to think that Jake
would have been calling his own sons "bro" while
they were growing up. Though that's not entirely
out of the question, as one Reddit user posited:
"Well they did learn an entire language
from a self-proclaimed jarhead."
Even if Jake himself didn't instill the
usage of the word "bro" in his kids,
there are other justifications for
its frequent usage. Jake isn't the
only Earth-born being living
on Pandora among the Na'vi.
A few of the scientists featured in the first
film, including fan-favorite Dr. Norm Spellman,
also chose to stick around the planet in the wake
of the first battle with the Sky People. Jake's
children and Spider are shown to have a convivial
relationship with these English-speaking humans,
so it's possible they could have picked
up on their slang over the years.
That would also explain why the slang feels
dated, if adults like Jake and Norm are their only
reference for American culture. Another potential
explanation: at the beginning of the film,
Jake narrates to the audience that he understands
the Na'vi language so well that it "may as well be
English," which essentially becomes a convenient
workaround for the movie's English dialogue.
"You do not know the sea."
"We will learn your ways."
If that's the case, perhaps the English we're
hearing isn't actually what's being said,
and "bro" is a translation of a more
appropriate Na'vi word. One Reddit
user even attempted to figure out what
the Na'vi equivalent would be, writing:
"I looked up a translator. 'Brother' in Na'vi
is 'Tsmukan.' I cannot decide what I like the
thought of more if I were hearing it
in their native language. Mukan, kan,
tsm, or tsmu ... I like tsmu. It sounds silly."